You already know that the word "language" refers to our ability to communicate with
Speech. But we saw that exactly ability, turned into a quagmire.
So let us now turn to the other thing that we mean by "language" - as you know, the specific languages
We speak their own words, their own rules and their own pronunciation.
I mean, English is a language, is not it? This is English! But that's the case.
Back in time, this was English. Even further, we call this English too.
Wait, I understand. This is the old English, this is the middle English, this is modern English.
So these three languages ​​or three different stages of the same language?
But I know that history is more forever than it wants to be. So let's just stick
Present. Here are some key words in English. These are the same words in full
Different tone of English. They have two dialects, if you get the same language
They occur in different ways by different groups of people, we call these different dialects.
Let's translate these words into Norwegian (Norwegian). Here's how we write
The same words are in Swedish (Swedish). So, Swedish and Norwegian are different languages,
But Britons and Scots have different dialects of the same language?
Where is the line between dialect and language anyway? Is it just arbitrary or conventional?
It may eventually be pressed through the Max Weinreich phrase passed. During the lecture
A series he gave in the 1940s, a member of his audience made a witty note, "Language is tone
With the army and navy. "If so, it is equally about politics and power
About rules.
Language vs. Languages, Languages ​​Versus Dialects ... Oh, what a mess your Jar! And
However, I welcome you to my YouTube channel. Sign up if you want to learn more, because
From the looks we got seriously stuff to sort together.